[Música]
bien
si ustedes recuerdan de esta escena de
flashdance en los años 80
todos ustedes son de mi generación
felicidades esta fue una escena que
seguramente fue repetida muchas veces
hasta que quedó perfecta pero si usted
no se recuerda de esta escena tal vez si
se recuerda de esta con el gato de shrek
cuando de igual forma quiso inmortalizar
esta escena donde se tiran agua y si aún
así no se recuerda de esta escena que
tal del público donde obviamente no
utilizó agua nuestras sociedades son
sociedades que nos gusta imitar copiar
todo lo que está de moda o como dicen
los jóvenes hoy en día los trending
topics
quien hizo el live bouquets challenge'
en el 2014
- el lifebook challenge' fue una
actividad la cual tenía un fin que era
recaudar dinero para todas aquellas
enfermedades que padecían de la
esclerosis lateral amiotrófica
de acuerdo a forks y a las estadísticas
fue un reto un ex buque challenge'
bastante exitoso se mencionó en twitter
más de 2.2 millones de veces se subieron
alrededor de 1.2 millones de vídeos
realmente logró en sólo dos meses y
medio mucho éxito recaudó 11.4 millones
de dólares ahora si nos ponemos a pensar
una cubeta de agua tiene alrededor de 20
litros
si multiplicamos esos 20 litros por el
1.2 millones de personas
tenemos 24 millones de litros de agua
que se utilizaron para esta actividad
pongámonos a pensar entonces en personas
de escasos recursos personas que
necesitan de este recurso aquí en
guatemala en el corredor seco o nos
podemos ir a países como australia
ciudad del cabo donde efectivamente 24
millones de litros significan mucho para
muchas personas
ahora si pensamos en que podemos
replicar esta actividad en ciudades como
california pues ya están proponiendo
multas de hasta 10 mil dólares realmente
ya el tema del valor del agua un valor
económico ya está surgiendo en australia
el gastar agua en la época seca
corresponde una multa entre 350 y 500
dólares al día a la persona que se le
ocurra gastar o desperdiciar agua por
alguna otra actividad
guatemala es un país hermoso estamos
bendecidos con 38 cuencas hidrográficas
tenemos tres vertientes donde nuestros
ríos fluyen tenemos alrededor de 24
lagos y lagunas 114 lagunetas y una
precipitación pluvial anual que va entre
1.800 y 2.200 milímetros realmente es
una gran bendición
adicionalmente esto favorece a la
agricultura y podemos en varias regiones
de guatemala aprovechar estas
condiciones climáticas para toda la
agricultura que hay en el país
podemos decir entonces que tenemos
abundancia correcto
ahora bien no solo somos ricos
naturalmente somos buenos somos felices
hoy por cierto 20 de marzo se celebra el
día internacional de la felicidad y
guatemala en eso sí sobresale estamos
catalogados en el número 29 de la lista
de las naciones unidas- de los países
que somos felices ya que tenemos riqueza
natural y tenemos riqueza en nosotros
mismos como sociedad
ahora bien siguiendo esta definición de
johnson you de the nature conservancy
dice que una sociedad se define no solo
por lo que crea sino por lo que se niega
a destruir y eso lo quiero repetir una
sociedad se define no solo por lo que
crea sino por lo que se niega a destruir
creen que como guatemaltecos nos podemos
definir con esta imagen
creen que esta imagen no nos representa
a nosotros esa sociedad feliz
este es el río villalobos un río que
corre a través de 14 municipios del
departamento de guatemala y sacatepéquez
es un río que tiene 2.500 litros por
segundo de aguas residuales y
adicionalmente recibe 1.5 millones de
toneladas de sedimento al año
si nosotros buscáramos en el diccionario
la definición de lo que es un río
ustedes creen que el río villalobos
encaja dentro de esa definición
será que como sociedad nos vemos
reflejados en esta imagen
tenemos que reaccionar y ya lo hemos
escuchado estamos en un punto crítico en
lo que se refiere al recurso hídrico
solo nosotros somos un 65% de agua y si
nuestro cuerpo está constituido en agua
de donde vamos a sacar este vital
recurso para sobrevivir
tenemos que reaccionar como sociedad ya
no está bien que ignoremos el problema
de la basura que ignoremos el problema
de que alguien tira basura y no lo
enfrentamos ya no podemos seguir
viviendo en casas apartamentos o
edificios que no tienen contadores
nosotros debemos exigir que se nos
regule el uso de los por medio de los
contadores
y qué pasa si se nos aumenta la tarifa
del agua reaccionamos violentamente
pero ese sí les aseguro que muchos de
nosotros tenemos el último modelo de
celular con el mejor plan que nos ofrece
el mercado dónde están nuestras
prioridades
será que le tenemos respeto a la
naturaleza
guatemala también sobresale porque
tenemos buenos guatemaltecos que a nivel
internacional se les reconoce tenemos
atletas tenemos cantantes tenemos
científicos que han hecho innovaciones a
nivel mundial
este es el típico guatemalteco que yo
quisiera que todos fuéramos y hoy aquí
solo por el hecho de que vinieron es
porque les interesa involucrarse en lo
que necesitamos hacer de forma urgente
que es rescatar nuestros recursos
hídricos ya no podemos seguir ignorando
el problema ya no podemos seguir
barriendo los problemas de contaminación
debajo de la alfombra el tiempo que
reaccionemos
yo les aseguro que ustedes como bien
decían ojos que no ven corazón que no
siente yo les aseguro que ustedes no
saben si tenemos o no un problema con
las aguas subterráneas como no lo vemos
no sabemos
la semana pasada tuve una reunión y de
mi oficina al punto de la reunión con
cuatro pipas de agua cuatro cisternas de
mi regreso que agarré por otra ruta
conté cinco cisternas eso ya es
alarmante eso significa que ya nuestros
mantos acuíferos están descendiendo
eso significa que muchos pozos ya se
están secando y hablando de pozos en
1965 se perforó el primer pozo que tenía
una profundidad aproximada de 137 metros
según datos de empagua existen pozos de
alrededor de 700 metros ya para el 2010
yo tengo comunicaciones verbales donde
nos dicen que ya se pasaron más de esos
700 metros de profundidad significa que
estamos buscando ese recurso que poco a
poco se va agotando y esto es lo que no
vemos
estos son unos mapas que se han
elaborado en funk agua donde hemos
mapeado la zona de recarga potencial
hídrica lo azul los mapas rojos el mapa
rojo muestra las zonas de extracción o
de lo que sacamos y si nos ponemos a
evaluar esta ecuación lo que se
infiltran y lo que se saca déjenme
decirles que estamos en números rojos
estamos en un desbalance en el uso del
agua en la región metropolitana y creo
que a muchos lo hemos sentido
para explicarles un poquito esta
información y para que ya podamos ver
qué es lo que está sucediendo en
nuestras aguas subterráneas este es un
estudio que realizamos en la func agua
donde analizamos varios municipios donde
nos dejaron monitorear sus pozos que ese
es otro tema el monitoreo de pozos en
este municipio la franja verde es la
superficie de la tierra la franja roja
es el fondo del pozo la franja negra es
un estudio que se hizo en 1978 que nos
permite tener la línea base y la línea
azul es lo que hicimos en la func agua
el año pasado sólo para santa catarina
pinula pudimos informarle a sus
municipalidades locales que tenían dos
pozos casi al borde de ese cárcel
este perfil les demostró visualmente que
el agua había descendido en un
aproximado de 200 metros en 40 años y
esto por qué porque al igual que santa
catarina pinula a muchos otros
municipios están creciendo guatemala
está creciendo se está transformando
tenemos información del ine donde en
1981 teníamos una población de un millón
311 mil habitantes
la información para el 2019 proyectada
es que estamos triplicando esa población
lo que significa que obviamente cada una
de estas personas necesitamos de este
vital recurso ahora si usted no vive en
la región de santa catarina pinula pero
vive más abajo como por mixco
déjeme asustarlo
este es el perfil de mixco
este estudio nos indicó que los niveles
de agua de mixco han descendido
alrededor de 400 metros en 40 años eso
es alarmante y eso lo podemos comprobar
con todas las noticias que hemos visto
en los medios de comunicación donde
vemos que ya en primera plana sale que
el municipio de mixco se está quedando
sin agua
estas son unas fotos aéreas de cómo ha
ido progresando guatemala desde el 1990
hasta el 2016 un crecimiento urbano
bastante acelerado
ahora bien esto es lo visible lo que
podemos ver hablemos entonces en
términos económicos
digamos que vivimos en vistahermosa 1 en
un edificio de 53 apartamentos este
edificio suple 12 mil galones diarios de
agua para la demanda de todas las
personas que viven en esos 53
apartamentos se necesitan 6 pipas
diarias para abastecer
a este edificio ahora si lo ponemos en
términos económicos el costo de una pipa
es de alrededor de 275 quetzales lo que
significa que el edificio tiene que
pagar 1650 quetzales diarios veámoslo al
mes 49 mil 500 quetzales de pipas
o sea que cada apartamento debiera de
pagar una mensualidad solo por el agua
de 900 33.96 cristales
por supuesto esto es totalmente
insostenible ya hemos visto que no es
sostenible económicamente y tampoco
naturalmente porque nuestros cuerpos de
agua están descendiendo los mantos
friáticos esas pipas que abastecen a
este edificio tienen una fuente de donde
sacan el agua que seguramente también
está descendiendo por eso es tiempo de
reaccionar
el caso de ciudad del cabo que les
aseguro es los que nos trae hoy aquí fue
muy particular
[Música]
lo particular es que en 1990 ellos le
informaron a su población que en 17 años
iban a tener el problema de escasez
hídrica si debido al cambio climático
eso los hizo reaccionar los hizo tomar
medidas de restricciones de cuotas
cuotas por persona y obviamente se
tuvieron que adaptar porque llegó el
momento 2018 donde las restricciones
llegaron hasta 650 litros por persona
por día imagínense vivir en 50 con solo
50 litros
quienes se bañan más de cinco minutos
les digo que consumen más de 300 litros
en ese momento
la ventaja de ciudad del cabo es que
tenían información y con esa información
pudieron capacitar a su gente
informarles y hacerles ver que las
restricciones eran necesarias
yo tuve la oportunidad de estudiar en
nueva zelanda por 5 años y aprendí mucho
de ellos
nueva zelanda es un país que está en el
top 10 de países con mejor calidad y
cantidad de agua hay regiones donde no
pagan agua aún así todos pero toda la
población tiene contadores
todos respetan sus cuotas y todos son
muy conscientes de que el agua es un
recurso que les sirve para todas sus
actividades desde que se levantan hasta
los fines empresariales comerciales
agricultores que ellos tienen ahí
entonces se trata de conciencia y
respeto
y es ahí donde hoy quiero que iniciemos
un trending topics diría mi hija
quiero que los quiero retar a que
hagamos tres cosas primero nos bañemos
en menos de tres minutos si realmente no
necesitamos tener el santuario en el
agua podemos hacerlo
segundo reto desconectar los aparatos
eléctricos cuando no están siendo usados
esa energía con solo dejar el aparato
eléctrico conectado esa energía y esa
energía proviene de una fuente de agua
de alguna hidroeléctrica
y el tercer reto es motivar a que otras
personas los hagan estos retos los reto
a que lo hagan de forma individual pero
también en sus empresas en sus trabajos
en sus centros de estudios sí y que
usemos el hashtag soy agua gt porque la
realidad es que somos en un 65% agua
ahora bien les pregunto ustedes creen
que el tema de agua en guatemala es de
abundancia o de escasez
o es de respeto y conciencia muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
t